new at 11 anti-racism in schools that
was the topic of tonight's ccsd board of
trustees meeting that once again turned
heated district leaders presented a
timeline for their plan to follow a
newly passed law in nevada 8 news now
reporter sasha loftis joining us live
from the clark county government center
with a bit more sasha
brian there was certainly a lot of
passion a lot of tensions on each side
tonight as people came out to speak out
about anti-racism in our schools now the
district actually did speak on the
policies they are moving forward with
this was first introduced back in june
after the passage of ab 371 in the
legislature that speaks on
attributing racism to bullying in
schools and adopting policies like this
throughout districts like ccsd now they
put that policy in place that timeline
for it to actually go into place in
january of 2022 some students saying it
is not soon enough they don't feel safe
in schools they are having issues with
racism in classrooms of course we will
continue to follow this throughout the
week as it continues one thing that was
mentioned was that critical race theory
will not be included in this particular
policy there's also was an was an
enactment of a task force that will of
course help develop these policies we
have a lot more information on this if
you'd like to check it out on our
website 8newsnow.com and of course on
all of our social media pages for now
reporting live downtown tonight sasha
loftis 8 news now